Introduction The Poetic Heart of a Lonely Dreamer
White Nights is one of Fyodor Dostoevsky's most
lyrical and tender works, a short story that
captures the fragile beauty of human connection and
the aching poignancy of solitude.
First published in 1848, early in Dostoevsky's career,
it belongs to a period before his more
mature philosophical and psychological novels such as Crime
and Punishment or The Brothers Karamazov.
Yet, despite its brevity and relative simplicity, White
Nights contains emotional and thematic depths that have
made it one of his most beloved and
enduring stories.
Set in the magical twilight of a St.
Petersburg summer, when the sun never fully sets
and the nights are awash in a surreal
silvery light, the story follows a solitary, unnamed
narrator, a dreamer who wanders the empty streets
at night.
He lives more in his imagination than in
the real world, finding comfort in fantasies and
silent buildings, in poetry and ideas.
But his quiet, repetitive life is interrupted when
he meets Nastenka, a young woman weeping on
a bench.
Over the course of four nights and one
morning, they share a brief, intense intimacy that
changes them both.
The story is not just a romantic interlude.
It is an exploration of the human need
to be seen, to be heard, to be
loved.
It is about the yearning for connection in
a world that often feels cold and distant.
Dostoevsky, who himself was prone to melancholy and
isolation, gives voice here to a character who
longs not for glory or wealth, but simply
for a moment of understanding.
Through the dreamer's confession, the reader is drawn
into a soul that feels deeply and asks
for very little, but finds that even a
little can be everything.
Unlike many of Dostoevsky's later characters, who are
torn by guilt, ideology, and inner chaos, the
narrator of White Nights is gentle, kind, and
almost painfully innocent.
He is a man untouched by cruelty, yet
marked by the pain of being invisible.
His love for Nastenka is pure and unselfish,
rooted not in desire but in a deep
emotional bond.
And that is what makes the story so
moving.
It is not about possession or fulfillment.
It is about giving without expecting, loving without
demanding, hoping even in the face of certain
loss.
Light, Shadows, and the Ephemeral Nature of Love
The setting of White Nights is more than
just a backdrop.
It is a vital part of the story's
emotional atmosphere.
The White Nights of St. Petersburg.
Petersburg, those luminous summer evenings where night never
fully arrives, mirror the dreamer's emotional state, a
space between darkness and light, between sleep and
waking, between fantasy and reality.
It is a time when ordinary life is
suspended and something otherworldly seems possible.
This luminous unreality is what makes the dreamer's
encounter with Nastenka feel so enchanted.
They meet not in daylight, where the world
imposes its rules and expectations, but in this
in-between space where hearts speak more freely.
For four nights, they walk and talk, sharing
their hopes and sorrows.
The dreamer opens up in ways he never
has before.
He is not trying to impress or manipulate.
He simply wants to be close to someone.
Nastenka, too, is lonely and vulnerable.
She tells him of her strict grandmother, her
confined life, and the man she loves who
promised to return but has not.
Their connection is real, but fragile.
They understand one another, yet they are not
meant to last.
The dreamer falls in love with Nastenka, but
she is still in love with someone else.
When her former lover returns, she goes to
him, and the dreamer is left alone once
more.
But Dostoyevsky does not present this as a
tragedy.
There is sadness, yes, but also beauty.
The dreamer has had his moment.
He was seen.
He was needed.
He was loved, even if briefly.
And for someone who has lived in the
shadows, that is no small thing.
His final words are not bitter, but full
of gratitude.
A whole moment of happiness.
Is that too little for the whole of
a man's life?
This line captures the spirit of White Nights.
It is a story about fleeting joy, not
because it is destined to vanish, but because
its very ephemerality gives it meaning.
The dreamer is not destroyed by disappointment.
He returns to his solitude, but something in
him has changed.
He has touched another soul.
He has known the light.
This emotional nuance is part of what makes
White Nights resonate so powerfully.
In a world where love is often portrayed
as dramatic, possessive, or transactional, Dostoyevsky offers a
vision of love that is quiet, selfless, and
tender.
A love that expects nothing and gives everything.
A love that, though brief, illuminates a life.
THE DREAMER, THE OUTSIDER, AND THE SEEDS OF
DOSTOYEVSKY'S THEMES White Nights is not just a
love story.
It is a portrait of the dreamer as
an outsider.
The narrator lives on the margins of life,
observing others, constructing imaginary relationships, and yearning for
a reality he cannot enter.
He is not mentally ill, nor is he
a social rebel.
He is simply alone, painfully aware of his
isolation, and yet he maintains a hopeful, even
childlike heart.
This figure of the dreamer would evolve in
Dostoyevsky's later works into more complex, conflicted characters.
Raskolnikov, the underground man, Prince Mishkin, Ivan Karamazov,
all share with the dreamer a sense of
dislocation, a struggle between inner vision and outer
reality.
But in White Nights, the dreamer is still
innocent.
He has not yet been hardened by suffering
or drawn into philosophical rebellion.
He still believes in the possibility of love,
kindness, and simple human connection.
What makes this story so valuable, especially within
Dostoyevsky's larger body of work, is its emotional
purity.
It shows the author in a more tender
mode, unburdened by religious or political weight.
There is no murder, no confession, no courtroom,
no philosophical duel, just two people walking through
twilight, trying to make sense of their hearts.
And yet, the themes that would come to
define Dostoyevsky's writing are already present.
The search for meaning, the pain of being
unseen, the dignity of suffering, the paradox of
joy and sadness coexisting.
Even the idea of redemption, not through ideology
or punishment, but through human connection, is here
in its earliest, gentlest form.
The form of the story, first-person narration,
framed as a confession or letter to the
reader, also anticipates Dostoyevsky's later narrative techniques.
The reader becomes a witness, not just to
events, but to emotion.
We are not told what to think or
feel.
We are invited to listen, to empathize, to
imagine ourselves in the dreamer's shoes.
White Nights also has a universal quality that
transcends time and culture.
Anyone who has ever felt invisible, who has
longed for connection, who has experienced a brief,
unforgettable love, will find themselves in these pages.
It is a story about moments, about how
the smallest encounter can echo through a lifetime,
about how the heart, even when broken, can
remain soft.
As you begin reading White Nights, let yourself
be drawn into its quiet world.
Feel the stillness of the city, the glow
of the sky, the hesitations and confessions of
the characters.
Let the story move slowly.
It is not meant to shock or thrill.
It is meant to make you feel gently,
honestly, deeply.
Welcome to White Nights, a tale for the
lonely, the hopeful, the dreamers.
A soft whisper in a sleepless night, a
reminder that even the briefest connection can light
up the soul.